okay
now we have done something seriously
if something else happens i'm about to
hulk out
yeah we'll give it a few seconds the
stream
is the stream good well like i said it
says
excellent right now but that doesn't
mean anything because it said that at
the beginning of the last one we'll wait
so yeah i [ __ ] did a hard reboot on
that router so that may have made a
difference
maybe so we'll see but we'll see i mean
we don't have that same title so
i was paranoid about that title we'll
see
i'm just i'm getting really mad okay i'm
getting really mad
okay we're at the 22. they're starting
they're starting to pile on yeah so
you know we'll edit it all together
people into one
well the audio one i will the video one
i'm not going to bother no
because it takes too long all right
dan says it's like the coast-to-coast
a.m call with a dude he said he worked
at area 51
yeah it kept dropping i remember
[ __ ] i love [ __ ] i love you i mean
we don't usually have this problem but
you know
i love [ __ ] coast to coast that was a
[ __ ] great radio show
they had somebody that was streaming
them with the old the old ones
uh on youtube and then that [ __ ]
disappeared after a while santa says
contact your provider i kind of feel
like it's probably that
i don't think so i don't think so i
think it might have been that router
maybe the right because i haven't i
haven't really done a hard reset on that
for a year at least at least a year
maybe 18 months so it may have been that
may have been what it was
i did a couple little saw reboots but i
didn't shut it all the way down you know
you're holding it in there for a minute
that little reset button in the back
and it [ __ ] going through the hole i
don't know what it is but it's
making me mad the the quality looks good
here what's the what's the speed say
does it say anything about the speed
because usually by now it would be
telling you to speak that's excellent
stuff
but like i said that's all it was maybe
just hope that's all it was
all right can we get back to the [ __ ] so
what you're saying
dude i'm only like calling me dude
i call everybody okay i'm only like a
third of the way through the [ __ ] okay
and you know t she calls me dude ain't
that song
i call anybody dude okay everyone is
dude
all right let's see what's going on
what is saying that the new
coast-to-coast sucks i haven't listened
to it actually we're up at 30 people
yeah [ __ ] people getting drunk yeah
me too
yeah well the more irritated i get the
drunker i want to get because i'm just
like dude just give me some more alcohol
i'm just getting really annoyed yeah
if i get to the end of the [ __ ] i'll be
really proud of myself all right xanada
if you got links to the old coast to
coast show
send me them [ __ ] off uh you know
offline or excuse me off the stream and
i want to check that [ __ ] out i'd like
to get back into that
even though shit's all [ __ ] it's
just a relaxing show
i remember when they were talking about
the mueller sky car any minute i thought
we were gonna have flying cars
everyone thought that yeah it turned out
that mueller was [ __ ]
embezzling money and then like the more
i thought about it i'm like people
should not have flying cars
yeah i've seen people like on ground
driving cars
and people should not like cars unless
they're completely ai controlled and
like that's some really good ai
yeah a human should not be piloting that
kind of [ __ ]
not by any stretch of the image died a
couple months back no that was a couple
years back now
wait was it i think garbel died a couple
years ago i don't remember
his wife died first i think and then i
think he died
our art was a [ __ ] gene art was a
[ __ ] genius man he was he was great
he was he was the [ __ ] howard stern
of paranormal
uh but strippers yeah but i say that i
say that with much love for the old
howard stern
but howard stern became irrelevant with
time thank you amanda
thank you very much they're [ __ ]
sending us them flash bulbs
i'm having a really hard time you guys
i'm just getting really really
frustrated it's gonna be all right
okay that's good go ahead and start with
my technology is not
doing what i need it to do and it's
making me very very angry
yeah he died in 2000 he said he died in
2018
so a couple years back oh okay yeah i
thought it was like just recently
well couple years you know i guess
that's kind of recently or whistle time
art knew how to [ __ ] take
any old [ __ ] topic and make that
[ __ ] sound
like it was [ __ ] you know i well he
is [ __ ]
that's one thing i will give him it's
like
no matter how batshit the people that
called him were
yeah he was able to take it seriously
and like not just laugh at them
he had good guests be sarcastic and [ __ ]
like because that's what i would have
done he had real good guests he had
linda molten howe come on he had the
dude [ __ ] talk about sedonium
[ __ ] all the time you know mars
elevator
[ __ ]
yeah he was cool and uh i believe he did
see
you i believe that art did see a ufo
which got him on to that
but um no it was just you never knew
what was going to happen on an art bell
show and it was like early days of the
internet
streaming was very difficult to do and
you had to get your little [ __ ]
am radio i think was am or fm i don't
remember i think
i think it was on am and you had to sit
there and dial in and hope you could get
art bell
and usually you got really shitty
reception you know depending on where
you lived but usually this real shitty
reception
and it was just like real mysterious to
hear our belt i grew up on that [ __ ]
[ __ ] it was another time it was just
well i understand like the allure of
that because
a lot of times when i'm working on other
[ __ ] like i will put some [ __ ] on on my
other computer which is like a youtube
video of like six hours of
you know creepy quote unquote true
stories from
reddit obviously they're not true
stories because they're about skin
walkers and whatnot
but they're still like cool to listen to
you know what i mean and there's like
rain in the background it's like really
atmospheric so i like to listen to that
while i'm working on other things yeah
so somebody in there said they didn't
that they hated the
linda bolton house shows aaron says 9.99
for more vodka for jenny's sanity
yeah i do need that thank you very much
thank you and we're back almost
but we're almost we're getting up to 50
again that was everybody got kicked out
we were running 70 for a while if i
could punch a computer you said [ __ ]
left
that's what i'm saying yeah yeah
yeah like i said and it's great to have
on in the background yeah there was
something about art's voice
it was just real relaxing and it could
took me back to another era
there was an era of mystery and not
really knowing it was before the
internet spoiled all that [ __ ]
there was a lot of there was a lot of
good things about that time period you
know
if i [ __ ] liked it you know really
good
but uh kind of missed those days yeah
well
yeah well [ __ ] goes on [ __ ] goes on
the world moves on so let's talk about
this [ __ ] because
i have a lot of [ __ ] yeah we got a lot
of [ __ ] okay i have a lot of [ __ ] to get
through still
and uh stream is still running strong i
mean
there's no yellow there's no yellow
[ __ ] warning line it looks good here
yeah i'm not getting any yellow okay all
right so let's
like talk about the [ __ ] quick all right
so um
other than all the child abuse and like
you know statutory rape allegations
thank you cat
thanks for keeping me feeling old well
you know all right mango who's up in the
eu
said not to sound paranoid but i think
google might have something to do with
it i noticed
in part four a message in the chat was
deleted and it said it was deleted by a
google moderator team
great show even with all the uh glitches
i'll check it tomorrow
but like i said i i feel bad like making
you like jump from a certain stream but
yeah my [ __ ] keeps like freezing up and
then my laptop keeps
freezing up and it's like i have to keep
restarting it it's like it's really
irritating yes
cat scent five bucks says thanks for
keeping me feeling oh oh knock it off
cat
it's gonna be all right we're not that
old matter of fact people aren't aged in
the same way you start seeing people in
their 40s and 50s they're still looking
good
it's not like it was better you know
that was 50 yeah i still look like
dewey yeah i'm 51. [ __ ] in well i
think i don't but you know
i think i look better now than i did in
my [ __ ] 40s
well you know whatever well i'm a man
men age differently
well the thing about dudes is that you
don't have that same expectation
of looking like perfect and young yeah
like
looking like you're 20 years old until
you're yeah but i do though i look in
the mirror and i go oh [ __ ] man i'm
getting old man
but then i'm like maybe i'll just scar
up and get one of my eyes blown out like
[ __ ] snake please that's what i mean
but like if that happened to a woman
nobody would ever want to sleep without
yeah i need to be missing an eye
you need to be missing an eye and
[ __ ] because see if if that happens
to dudes women are like oh intriguing
that means he has like an interesting
backstory yeah
that happens to a woman everybody's like
ooh freak yeah
just saying you guys have it easy mark
says my poetry guys is causing the frame
it could be that you maybe it's that
maybe you need to knock it off t
says 50s or the new 30s i think they
kind of are um
in a lot of ways i do think that's true
well look this is no [ __ ] now
if i were to get on a uh
probably getting a time machine go back
to the year 1099 and go [ __ ] meet
charles martel
and [ __ ] start in the [ __ ] you
know islamic repulsion
excuse me the christian repulsion of
islam during the first crusade and it
froze up again
what the [ __ ] well nope if i did that
it froze up again on my end it did
damn i'm getting okay no it's back it's
i'm getting really pissed off
i'm getting pissed off i'm getting
pissed off if i went back there they
would be amazed that i still had
my old all my teeth they'd be like you
got your own you got your teeth
well there's 50. yeah and then get on
the bench and be able to bench press
three times what their [ __ ] 18 or 19
year olds could bench press back in
those days
they would have been amazed modern
people are just not like
ancient people brother except maybe the
romans the romans worked out a lot
okay is everybody here should we try to
start this [ __ ] yeah can we please get
back
start this [ __ ] i'm gonna feel really
bad we don't even get to the [ __ ]
siege man
they said that it froze up but they
could hear us okay all right
let's just hurry up and try to finish
the time yeah we're fine it's like we it
froze up on our end for
like a little bit but look louis do not
want us to finish this show
but okay it might be we're going to do
it it might be a hot top it might be a
topic they don't want us talking about
but like i said i don't really see why i
i mean
well here's the thing though netflix did
a whole mini series on this [ __ ]
called waco yeah but that's them talking
but that was 2018
yeah that was a couple years ago so it's
not like anybody's like this is not like
a hot
that was them talking about it it has to
do with who's spinning the narrative
but okay go ahead let's try to finish it
let's try to finish the show i don't
know i think it's probably just
our [ __ ] i don't think so all right
so well okay look at the stream and see
how good the [ __ ]
see see if it's [ __ ] up oh it froze
again all right
oh i can't i can't
come on